in the past decade a new paradigm has
transformed computer graphics lighting
and shading pipelines 20 years ago
renderers were limited because computers
were slower and they use approximated
techniques for lighting scenes because
of these approximations an object
reflecting the light might look real in
one light but fake in another the
approximations wouldn't hold up
everywhere now current renderers can
simulate the full physical nature of
light and how it bounces around in a
room this is very complicated and
computationally intense ok luckily we
have this extraordinary book that
explained and shared the technology
first published in 2004 physically based
rendering is a complete source code
implementation it's also a textbook
that's on everybody's reading this I
have a copy on my Kindle just kidding
this word has been widely adopted in
shading and lighting systems by making
the technology accessible the visual
effects community embraced it completely
for formalizing and providing reference
implementation of the concepts behind
physical physically based rendering as
presented in their book physically based
rendering the Academy presents the
technical achievement award to Matt Farr
Greg Humphries and Pat Hanrahan Wow I'd
like to thank my wife Kathy for coming
out here with me and being the person
that she is thanks also to the academy
and especially the nominating committee
for they had a really tough task this
year and we know there were a lot of
excellent candidates thank you very much
you know I think all three of us are
still in awe of the effects that we see
when we go to the movies even though we
know how all the sausage gets made and
it's really humbling to see how our
little labor of love has had such an
impact on the film industry so we are
incredibly grateful to everyone who used
our book to understand or advance the
state of the art or educate their
students or colleagues or themselves so
the great big thank you to all our
readers and all of our users
so needless to say when we started
writing a book we never expected an
Academy Award would be the end result of
that effort
we'd like to also thank Donald Knuth who
invented this idea of literate
programming and it's this kind of
radical idea actually which is that
computer programs should be written as
much for people to read as for computers
to execute and our book is a literate
program and we think this approach this
technique for kind of introducing ideas
and explaining them has been integral to
whatever impact the book has had so
thanks Don I'd like to thank Deirdre who
famously let me bring the manuscript for
the book on our honeymoon the the far
girls
Sheila Megan who I hope will read this
at some point and my parents are here
today for early encouragement and access
to computing resources thank you you
know the ability to do realistic
lighting simulation has been one of the
dreams of computer graphics for the last
twenty years we just want to acknowledge
some of the pioneers in that field in
particular Turner Whitted Don Greenberg
Jim ghujiya
and ken Torrence who really laid the
foundations for all we did
and finally I want to thank Dowell my
wife who for many years tolerated a copy
of chamber soccer's radio transport
theory on my bedside table every night